Was da gestern von der nasa und google verkündet wurde war wirklich eine riesensensation
Das könnte die suche nach außerirdischen tatsächlich auf ein paar jahre verkürzen zum ersten mal hat die nasa mit unterstützung von
künstlicher intelligenz
einen planeten entdeckt unterstützt wurde sie dabei von google genauer von
Google, brain was das alles bedeutet und warum wir jetzt schon bald auf außerirdische stoßen könnten jetzt den klicks in science fiction herzlich willkommen
Das thema künstliche intelligenz hatten wir ja hier schon öfter mal alle großen
it konzerne forschen daran und es gibt heftige diskussionen über nutzen und gefahren anfang an
Waren elon musk und stephen hawking vor der technologie mark zuckerberg von facebook sieht er die vorteile
Jetzt wird sie also zum ersten mal bei der planeten suche eingesetzt und das mit einer spektakulären
premiere für diese premiere ließ das forschungsteam google brain anhand von
15.000 bestätigten planeten signalen trainieren was genau auf einen planeten
hindeutet der nasa-satellit keppler untersucht sterne nach helligkeitsschwankungen
Treten die in einem festen rhythmus auf zieht ein planet an dem stern vorbei mit diesem training erzielten sie eine
96 prozentige trefferquote bei google bringen nach diesem training wurde google brennt auf bereits schon untersuchte
670 sterne angesetzt und wurde tatsächlich
Bei, kepler 90 50 google break fand in den daten einen weiteren planeten dran sind um den
2545 lichtjahre entfernten stern spürte die cas software einen achten stern auf zwar ist der mit 400 grad celsius
oberflächentemperatur viel zu heiß aber die sensation ist eigentlich eine andere mit hilfe der software können jetzt exoplaneten tatsächlich am
Fließband aufgespürt werden bis heute sind es ja schon knapp
3700 exoplaneten die in rund
2700 sternensystemen entdeckt wurden mit google bringen könnte diese planeten jetzt viel schneller entdeckt werden jetzt müssen
forschungsteams nicht mehr selbst die daten analysieren sondern das macht google branding zukunft wir sind natürlich müssen sie von den forschungsteams
bestätigt werden aber die chancen dass wir erstens
im nächsten jahr tausende weitere exo planeten entdecken sind riesig und das wir zweitens auch gezielter nach erdähnlichen planeten
Suchen können das ist jetzt viel leichter möglich das forschungsfeld kann jetzt so
modifiziert werden dass sich nur noch auf exo planeten in der habitablen
zone konzentriert wird also da wo es leben geben kann das james webb, weltraumteleskop
das die leistung des hubble-weltraumteleskops
Um ein vielfaches übertreffen wird kann sich dann auf diese planeten konzentrieren das wird nämlich in der lage sein wasser
kohlendioxid und sauerstoff in der atmosphäre der planeten aufzuspüren
Beim vorbeiflug an ihrem zentralen stern kann das teleskop das sternenlicht dass durch die atmosphäre der planeten strahl
untersuchen und diese elemente aufspüren während sie vorhanden wäre das ein klares indiz für leben mit der vorarbeit von kepler in der
kombination in google bringen könnten dann tatsächlich schon nach dem status james webb, weltraumteleskop
2009 10 die ersten planeten gefunden werden die dann höchstwahrscheinlich leben beherbergen
Die nächsten jahre werden also extrem spannend wenn er kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken chat mit einem toten
Da geht es darum wie google bringt einen toten als
Jackpot auferstehen lässt der absolute wahnsinn ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran